[Music]
joining us now dr mehmet oz who is one
of the gop contenders in the senate
primary in pennsylvania coming up in
just days doctor great to have you with
us
great to be here shannon let's start
with this has gotten to be an incredibly
tight race i want to pull up some fox
news polling brand new on this it has
got you at the top of the pack at 22
percent uh mccormick follows you at 20
burnett at 19 that's essentially within
our margin of error so i want to give
you a chance to hear from your critics
and a chance to respond as you all are
all neck and neck at this point here are
some jabs at why you aren't as qualified
as they are
the reason memo keeps talking about
president trump's endorsement is because
he can't run on his own positions and
his own records and what's true is that
he has flip-flopped on every major issue
we're talking about in this campaign
when these carpet baggers lose you will
never see them again and if they should
win you will never see them again
is former president trump's endorsement
enough for the voters of pennsylvania or
do you offer them more
i offer lots more although it helps
tremendously president trump's
endorsement opens people's minds you
know they call you back they take
meetings which is an important
opportunity for a candidate to
articulate why they're the best person
i'm strongly pro-life strongly in favor
of the second amendment ted nugent
endorsed me these are two attacks by the
way that have come up that are driven by
35 million dollars of negative
advertising primarily from outside
pennsylvania but the voters have figured
that out and as president trump warned
me you know when you're an outsider the
insider the establishment they come
after with everything they've got and
i've been able to stand on my own two
feet very proudly and and and live up to
the promise of my campaign which is to
identify why washington's getting it
wrong why are they not aligned with our
values and knowing that i can go to
washington and be a bold loud voice for
our commonwealth is what everyone in
that i talk to is looking for and i can
deliver that because i've been doing it
on television and in my operating room
for many years so let's talk about the
issue that has been one of those level
against you is that you flip-flopped on
the issue of abortion here are your two
primary opponents on that
i've seen him on numerous occasions and
specifically at the breakfast club
saying that my life was nothing more
than a uh acorn with electrical currents
i am wondering if the good doctor has
now since changed his position on that
if you go back to that breakfast club
interview he taxed the pro-life for uh
picking fights he attacks states that
put in pro-life legislation is
disrupting business and this is
something that you have to deal with
mammoth because you've got a track
record that's completely opposite
okay so that breakfast club interview
was a radio interview back in 2019 in
which you said that you were pro-life
but you wouldn't interfere with everyone
else's stuff is the quote because it's
hard enough to get into life as it is so
what about the accusation that you have
flipped or changed on that position
i was clear in that interview and it's
the only one they keep talking about
that i was against the law from alabama
that would ban abortions and all
exceptions and i'm of the belief as a
doctor that if the life of the mother is
truly at risk that will be an exception
that is acceptable and i understand
kathy barnett doesn't like that uh and i
use a heart surgeon respect the sanctity
of life i believe life starts at
conception i take care of babies when
they're first born i know this
specialness
of a baby and nine months earlier it's
still life but she's raised questions in
her own candidacy that she's refused to
answer as i'm answering yours right now
she has supported black lives matter and
one today statue of president obama uh
in in place of other structures that are
sacred to our country should attack the
founder of our country george washington
as well as attacking president trump and
what's ironic is big money groups never
trump groups have now come into
pennsylvania with outside money and
they're wrongly supporting kathy barnett
and putting her in contention and this
is a candidate who lost by 20 points
when she ran for congress 18 months ago
so she's not going to do on the general
election which is why president trump is
over and over again even today put out a
new
announcement saying that i'm the one to
support because i can win in november
and that's what we need is republicans
another senator uh to take the place of
the currently retired republican senator
in pennsylvania if you want that you
should vote for dr oz which is i think
why i'm still leading in the polls well
they are tight they are within the
margin of error she is surging at what
is a good time for her i am going to
speak with her in a couple of days and
will ask her those questions that are
now bubbling up uh dr oz in the meantime
great to have you
god bless take care hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else